こんにちは
私は約20年前にここ仙台の東北大学で新しい研究所を立ち上げました。
私は学生を励ますため
に航空宇宙工学部のエル教授に任命
されました。
私
は私たちの研究の目標を揚げることです。
私のバックグラウンドはロボット工学であるため、宇宙への夢私たちの
具体的な夢は、ロケットが必要なもの
を揚げるために未知のものを探索するためのロボットの開発
です。
この日米共同
プロジェクトは、ホレス
が国際学生衛星に打ち上げを割り当てると名付けられました。
打ち上げ場所はネバダ州のブラックロックデザートです。
ロケット
はまだ宇宙空間ではない高度4000メートルの空を飛ぶことができますが、
このプロジェクト
は学生にユニークな機会を与えます。
このプロジェクトの標準サイズの給与について話す宇宙システムの開発の実際のプロセスを実行します
約3億5000万個の小さなソーダ
ポップ缶のサイズであるため、このプロジェクトは
キャンセルされたプロジェクトゼロと呼ばれました。これは
パラシュートを使用した打ち上げと下降の写真です。1999年にコンサートプロジェクトが開始され
、今日、アイデアは
世界中にさまざまな色のソーダポップに広がっています。 缶
は空に打ち上げられ、上空
のイバディス空気
は圧力を測定します。
ラジオの学生が撮影した写真は
、このプロジェクトからの貴重な教訓をいくつか打ち立てまし
た。次のステップは
、このための揚げられた実際の宇宙空間です。
質量1キログラムの10×10×10センチメートルの立方体フォーマットで揚げられた宇宙が今日提案されました。この前者
はCubeSatとして知られ
ています。
日本の宇宙飛行士によって国際宇宙ステーションから軌道に乗せられました
これは地球の写真ですが、
小さな小さな立方体を見つけることができますか
この写真の衛星これらは
学生が作った衛星であり、これらは
私たちのCubeSat Reichelによって撮影された画像ですこれ
は私の最初の夢が実現したまさにその瞬間です
学生が作った衛星
は宇宙環境で適切に機能し、
写真を撮って
データを地上に送信します ステーションですが、私たちの
夢は終わりがありません。
この新しい目標に向けてリモートセンシングの重要な科学を実行する能力を備えたより大きな衛星を開発し続けています。私の学生は
一生懸命働き、素晴らしい仕事をしました。新しい
衛星のサイズは50センチメートルです。
は約
50キログラムですこのフォーマットは
マイクロサテライトと呼ばれ、これは私たちの最初の
マイクロサテライトの上昇であり、5年
後に私たちは上昇を完了しましたそして
質問は私たちがどのように宇宙に行くことができるかという
ことです
ここにあるマイクロ衛星
は、10万キロ以上のジャクソンの巨大な高価な
衛星であるゴセットを見る logramsは
数億ドルで、
私たちのマイクロ衛星がどれほど小さいかを知ることができます
が、それはそれらへの小さな追加ですが、
2009年1月に1つ上昇し、2014年5月に上昇するために両方の
衛星が現在 軌道と
特に上昇は
目覚ましい成果を上げています。これらは、広角カメラを搭載
した地球の写真です。
画質が大幅に向上し、巨大な
台風も搭載カメラで撮影されました。
これは、上昇との比較です。
光
と日本の気象衛星が左に撮ったものを画像化するために、
学生が作った大学の衛星は
プロの大規模衛星と競争することができます
2また、都市と家と田んぼ
の風景をクローズアップしたカラー望遠鏡カメラを持ってい
ます 日本では、これは5メートルの
解像度の画像であり、
世界クラスの最高の結果であり、この形式の
マイクロ衛星
は驚くべきものであり、
マイクロサテライトへの挑戦は、100から1までのコストについて言えば、
成功したより小さく、より速く、より速い開発をもたらしましたが
、驚くべき
品質は、単一の衛星でのさまざまな
リモートセンシングミッションに十分です
が、地球のカバレッジは
非常に限られていますが、  1億
ドルの予算がある場合は、高価な大型衛星を1つではなく、48のマイクロ衛星を使用することをお勧めします。
これらの衛星は
、地球全体をシームレスに
シームレスにカバーできるため
、地球の災害
監視ネットワークを24時間監視できます。 たとえば、今や私たちの
夢は決して終わらないので
、プロジェクトの癌が成功した後、ネバダに戻って
、
学生の競争とマイクロローラーについての別の新しいアイデア
を思いつきました。
彼らは自律的に帰宅し
、ロボットは地上を移動する際に一対の油で飛ぶことができます
着陸後、私の学生は私たちにそのような
二輪ロボットの設計をしました。なぜなら、この
形状はロケットの円筒形に収まることができるからです。
質量は
CubeSatと同じ約1キログラム
です。
新しい
学生が私の研究室に入学した年、私
は彼らに新しいロボット小説になるように頼みました
、そして数年後
、デザインはより洗練されました
これは
2008年の非常に美しい打ち上げ
とパラシュートでの学生の挑戦のビデオクリップですそしてロボットの
秋に着陸した後 地上
では役に立たないため、パラシュートモジュールを自律的に切り取り
、ストロークの感情を解決し始めます。ドキドキする速度
は非常に速く
、ロボット
がゴールフラグに向かって移動するGPS座標によって保護されていますが、地面
は必ずしも簡単ではありません。 自動的
に出て行こうとしましたが、
ついにゴールフラグが出てみんな
興奮していたので、
この7年間のレボの結果です 学生
プロジェクトのおかげで、今日は
このステージに茶の木の名前が付いた新しいモデルの下部を持ってくることができて
とてもうれしいです。ここに来てください。
とてもかわいいし、とても素敵に
デザインされているので、これは
かつてこのテトリスの以前のバージョン
であり、車載カメラ
と車載カメラの画像が搭載されていた日本のSun doenでの最近のフィールドテストビデオは非常に
エキサイティングです。今、私たちの夢はこのロボットを月面に運ぶことです。
forceはGoogleLunarX PRIZEです。これは、
Googleが3,000万米ドルで主催する世界規模のコンテストです。 合計でドルの現金
賞金は
、非政府機関である必要があります。
ロボットを月に送り、
500メートル以上の表面で楕円形のトラブルを発生させ、
高品質の画像を送信
するルールは単純ですが、現時点で達成するのは簡単ではありません。
今日、さまざまな国からの18のチーム
が
競い合っ
ており、この挑戦的なレースの主要グループに現在参加している
1つの日本のチームがあります
。 日本語のムーンシラサギは、最近
発表された
恐怖の準備ができた技術の証明のための2つのロボットモデルを持っています。1つは
ムーンレイカーと呼ばれ、もう1つは
テトリスです。  2キログラムで
ありながら高度な技術が
これらの小さなボディに完全に実装されています。
たとえば、このホイールは3Dプリントを備えた超強力プラスチック材料で作られています。
技術私たち
はティーザーで接続された方法でこれら2つのロボットを操作
しますXプライズルールは
厄介な場所を指定しませんが
、2007年に洞窟があるエキサイティングな目的地があります
日本の月の溶岩洞
は月の表面に小さな穴を発見し、科学者
はそれらを推測します
地下の月の溶岩
洞の自然のトンネルや洞窟に穴や天窓を開けると、これらの場所
は、近代化された
温度と
宇宙線や隕石の影響からの自然保護の観点から、将来の人間の定住に非常に適して
います。 穴の端
大きなルーブルはアンカーとして
残り、小さなローバーのタイトルリストは穴に落ち
ます。このビデオクリップはこのアイデアを示しています。これ
は小さな洞窟でのデモンストレーションですが
、同じアイデアは
地下の地下探査の後、より深い垂直の穴でも機能します。
この赤ちゃんローベル
はティーザーを巻き上げることで回収できる
ので、XPrizeは
非政府のプラを奨励します
革新的な技術と新しいビジネス
スペースプログラムに挑戦する人は、限られた数のエリートメンバーのためではありませんが、
誰もがオープンな競争に参加できるようにする必要が
あります。 進行が遅く、
立ち入り禁止の種類と恐竜の種類です
が、マイクロ衛星と地ビールはゲームを変えることができ
ます
小さな低コストと
アジアの宇宙プログラムのための良いアイデアがたくさんあります最も重要なこと
はしきい値を下げて数を増やすこと
です 新しいプレーヤーは特に
若い人たちを連れてき
ますスペースはあなたのニッチに非常に近いです
衛星の手とロボットの手は
それを実現することができます
私たちに参加してください
みんなと興奮を共有しましょうありがとう